recessions are not fun times for most
people as tens of millions get laid off
hundreds of companies go bankrupt and
billions of dollars are lost across the
board one sector that seems especially
prone to losses during a recession is
the luxury market as people cut back on
things they don't need for instance
revenue for high-end department stores
plummeted 25% in 2009 when company by a
70 percent price reduction however this
is not the case for luxury brands during
the same time period Louis Vuitton's
revenue flatlined
while Richemont actually increased by
2.4 percent some luxury brands did see
decreases up to 10 percent but for the
most part luxury brands fared much
better than average retail store and
mouths better than a stock market which
almost halved in value so why do luxury
brands thrive in recessions
[Music]
the thing is truly wealthy people don't
lose money during recessions they
actually make money during the last
recession the wealthiest five to ten
percent of Americans actually saw their
share of the country's wealth increased
between 2007 and 2009 as a result luxury
brands stopped accommodating for wannabe
rich people and brought baseline
products that are mainly intended for
this crowd
instead they increase the quality of all
of their products and increase the price
accordingly plus a lot more
in fact back hunter and online reseller
found that the price of the Chanel
classic medium flat bag increased 72
percent between 2011 and 2017 and almost
doubled in price from 2,500 at the start
of the recession in 2008 to $49 and
platinum Dean similarly the New York
Times found that between January 2008
and May 2009 instead of tearing down
branding and decreasing prices Louis
Vuitton and Gucci ocupados flashier
products with more conspicuous logos
this abrupt change actually led to an
increase in profits for both companies
in the European handbag divisions inside
the US Louis Vuitton's revenue remained
stagnant while Gucci's revenue actually
increased by 40 and a half percent
Hermes actually produced some of the
largest profit margins in its history
before and during the recession you see
people who are truly Balti don't shop
luxury brands with a fashion statement
or the status but rather for the quality
they look for custom craftsmanship like
you find in a high-end suit or a bespoke
rolls-royce considering this wealthy
individuals are actually more attracted
to these brands when their main focus is
on quality rather than fashion aside
from a more refined target demographic
recessions give luxury brands the
opportunity to connect directly with
their audience as well people looking to
buy luxury brands flocked towards two
retail stores and online stores of the
luxury brands themselves as many
wholesalers closed down many of their
storage during recessions this direct
link to customers helps to develop brand
loyalty and garner more long-term
customers next up recessions drive
traffic to certain luxury industries
that hold value for the most part this
is various types of jewelry whether a
Rolls Royce
watch or diamond necklace during
recessions commodities like gold and
diamond generally drop in price as a
result jewelry stores can offer their
jewelry at much cheaper prices and still
make a good profit as a raw materials
themselves are cheaper many rich
individuals really like commodities as
investments often times even more than a
classic stocks bombs and real estate
these people buy up hundreds of
thousands and even millions of dollars
in various types of jewelry in England a
jewelry industry to pull in substantial
revenue even during the worst of
recessions moving on luxury brands also
start to focus more on an international
audience specifically on countries that
have not been affected by the recession
as much this is generally in
up-and-coming countries where even a
negative impact will simply result in
smaller quote rather than negative
growth in the last recession this was
mainly China before the last recession
China's manufacturing industry was
growing exponentially along for the GDP
to skyrocket growing ten to fifteen
percent year after year as a result even
with the depths of the recession though
China's GDP growth rate was
significantly impacted it was still
largely positive at over five percent
this outstanding economic performance
allowed many business moguls to continue
growing and making more profits making
it easier for them to afford imported
goods the Chinese one is a paid currency
meaning that market forces don't affect
the value of the currency however
generally the currency values of
countries are significantly
outperforming Western countries at any
given time period will significantly
increase as a result luxury goods
produced in Western markets will become
substantially cheaper in these
up-and-coming countries making it
available to a much larger audience in
fact the vast majority of the growth
immediately following the last session
was because of a rapid increase in
luxury good consumption in China clearly
targeting countries that are
comparatively doing better in a
recession can be very lucrative
something else has very lucrative for
luxury brands during recessions is
increased
exclusivity one of the fundamental
appeals to luxury brands aside from
their quality and functionality of the
product is that they offer exclusivity
and when the entire mark
is on downturn and much less wannabe
richie-poo are in the market these
luxury brands become significantly more
exclusive and of course certain affluent
people are drawn more towards luxury
brands when they are more exclusive so
overall during recessions luxury brands
shift their focus onto affluent members
of society and international customers
which is further aided by wealthy people
wanting to invest in certain commodities
and her eye for quality and exclusivity
this allows luxury brands to build a
stronger more loyal customer base
enabling them to not just stay afloat
but largely outperformed the entire
market if you guys thought this video
provided good analysis of the most
popular survival tactics used by luxury
brands during recessions then make sure
drop a like and consider subscribing to
see more questions logically answered
but until then I'm hari I'll see you
guys on the next one